uh we've talked now for a while about
how if the american right
is really harping on the left is doing
this
we should really be considering whether
it is they themselves that are doing it
this is called projection this is
accusing others of doing that which you
are doing
and when it comes to free speech and
cancel culture the right has been making
a living in some cases literally making
a living when it comes to some of these
right-wing media outlets by saying the
left wants to cancel anybody they don't
agree with and the left wants to take
away your free speech we have a
fascinating but disturbing new
report
about the book ban effort and book ban
efforts have hit their highest level in
at least 20 years and it is not the left
that is doing it it is the right that is
trying to do it so we are going to look
at this report from the american library
association it was released earlier this
week the report found over 700
challenges to library school and
university materials in 2021 this is the
most since at least 2000 the ala has
only been tracking such efforts since
the year 2000 so we can say it's been at
least 20 years but maybe more
axios goes on to say
book bans have risen substantially over
the past year as conservative groups
have challenged public school libraries
and successfully purged books from those
libraries generally about lgbtq issues
which they like to frame as you know
inappropriate
gender and sexuality indoctrination and
books about people of color which they
often like to frame as teaching white
people to feel bad or critical race
theory or whatever the case may be
now there's a bunch of different
important elements to this that we need
to talk about first is again and i'm
going to say this a bunch of times this
is right wingers
this is right wingers doing this they
say they are for free speech but they
want to ban or challenge books
they say they are against canceling but
they want to cancel authors of books or
cancel a teacher's right or ability to
say here's the material i want to teach
with
and here's how i'm going to teach with
it they are the ones who are the experts
in education but it is random people say
no no you shouldn't be allowed to do
that
now
that is the projection and hypocrisy
piece oftentimes you know the people
most loudly talking about free speech
are the ones trying to limit it
when is it okay to ban books is it ever
okay to ban books in this there is an
important and serious conversation to
have in other words are we saying
block certain books from being published
basically never there is essentially
never
uh
we might be able to come up with a
couple of examples of when we are saying
it should be against the law for a
publisher to even publish certain books
are we saying
don't have certain books in certain
libraries okay well so let's now imagine
should there be pornography in an
elementary school library
no should there be books that are
instruction manuals on how to make bombs
in elementary school libraries probably
not
but here we're already talking about age
restrictions that's very different than
a ban
and then there's the question of well
what about as part of class curriculum
should
eight-year-olds have certain materials
as part of their class curriculum and
there my idea is similar to my view on
responsible platforming sometimes i'll
interview a lunatic extremist uh we used
to interview the people from that
westboro baptist church and we would get
emails sometimes from people saying you
shouldn't have these people on because
you're platforming them and my response
was responsible platforming means i've
determined the views are worth exposing
and i feel equipped to make it clear
that the views are disgusting and that
was the difference between some of the
interviews i would do and some of the
ones that that you would see elsewhere
similarly i i would apply the same kind
of test when it comes to school
curriculum
uh i understand saying you know
we don't want teachers teaching hitler's
mind conf
unless they are equipped to teach it
correctly and to teach it in a way that
makes it abundantly clear that these are
the disgusting views of a xenophobic
authoritarian maniac who had six million
jews killed
it starts to get more complicated
there's not one answer but the point
here is
we are not saying
ban the book
we are not saying burn the book
and i remember in my high school history
of film class there were
discussions about
what movies is it okay for
14 year olds to watch what level of
gratuitous violence and sexuality is
okay for the classroom doesn't mean
you know throw away what what at the
time were dvds doesn't mean don't allow
parents to but there were questions like
what is appropriate for 14 year olds to
watch in school it's a fair question is
it too sexually explicit and then we get
to
the hypocritical aspect of the book bans
that they demand
and that can't be ignored because
they'll say oh this is too sexually
explicit
but they're okay with
the sexuality that's in the bible which
is extreme and significant they say this
is too violent but they're okay with all
of the violence in the bible they make
exceptions there so the hypocrisy is a
major component there is a real
conversation to be had here and in
almost all cases we shouldn't be banning
books but we can't even have that
conversation with the right because they
just want them axed they want to decide
what teachers are allowed to do they
want to decide what librarians are
allowed to have in the library and it's
a bad faith conversation from the ground
up let me know your thoughts you can
find me on twitter at dpakman and let me
know what you think